you buy a house for a hundred thousand
dollars guys right you only put down
twenty thousand you put twenty percent
down the bank gives you the other eighty
thousand you put twenty thousand dollars
into the property to fix it up that
property now goes up to two hundred
thousand then you can go ahead and do a
Cash out refinance and you can pull out
what seventy percent remember you only
put in about forty thousand dollars of
your own money into the deal now you're
getting 140 000 out you can take that
140 tax free which is the key yeah and
roll it into buying another asset that's
gonna make you more money and you ain't
paying it your tenants aren't right so
why not continue to do that and Buy and
Hold This is